alors en une fraction de seconde le feu
se propage sur tout votre corps vous
vous transformez en torche vivante
nous accueillons notre terrien du samedi
21 ce soir Sébastien Maillard
alors Sébastien Maillard bonsoir le
premier mai 2000 l'explosion d'un
réservoir de camions vous laisse pour
mort le corps brûlé à 92%
le problème si vous étiez sur le point
de vous marier et là soutenu par votre
fiancée vous êtes battus puis vous avez
fondé une famille puis vous avez
retrouvé goût à la vie bref vous avez
repris votre existence là vous l'aviez
laissé vous nous raconterez votre
histoire à 20h
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Sébastien Maillard bonsoir vous êtes né
le 30 juin 1977 à Montreux en Suisse
père chauffeur de poids lourds mère
femme au foyer alors pendant votre
jeunesse vous êtes un garçon plutôt
sportif vous faites du volley-ball vous
faites de la course à pied à
l'adolescence après 4 ans
d'apprentissage vous êtes embauché dans
un garage
mais c'est grâce au volley-ball que vous
allez rencontrer la femme de votre vie
Karine à 20 ans vous décidez de vous
installer ensemble dans un petit
appartement en 2000 vous trouvez un
nouvel emploi de mécanicien dans un club
de golf et vous décidez d'emménager avec
Karine dans une petite maison et surtout
de vous marier voilà la date fixée c'est
juillet 2000 tout est prêt à l'église à
la mairie la réception les faire-part
sont partis il ne manque que la bague au
doigt et l'affaire sera concluant en
avril 2000 Vous annoncez à votre patron
que vous allez travailler donc dans ce
club de golf à partir du 1er mai
mais le préavis est trop court il vous
demande de rester encore un peu
le 1er mai vous devez réparer au
chalumeau le réservoir d'un camion
militaire vous n'avez jamais fait ça
vous avez toujours refiler ça au chef
d'atelier mais là le chef d'atelier est
occupé
et là vous approchez du réservoir avec
le chalumeau un jet de flamme va vous
sauter au visage comme un lance-flamme
c'est vrai que j'ai commencé à chauffer
puis à un moment donné je voulais voir
si ça suffisait il affirme est passé sur
l'embouchure et puis là ça fait le jet
flamme alors une fraction de seconde le
feu se propage sur tout votre corps vous
transformez en torche vivante d'habitude
on pense à sa vie passée et vous vous
pensez à votre vie future vous pensez à
Karine vous pensez à votre mariage vous
pensez à la vie que vous n'aurez pas
avec elle l'année 2000 était censée être
une grande année
lune de miel et tout tout était prévu
déménagement changement de travail et ça
a été une grande année mais pas dans le
sens où je m'y attendais quoi
alors la veste du fils du patron du
garage ne suffit pas il faut un
extincteur pour vous éteindre ouais
effectivement le fils de mon patron est
arrivé sur les lieux on entend dans
l'écrit puis en voyant les flammes puis
là il a pris sa veste il m'a éteint puis
quand il a commencé à éteindre il a
repris sa veste pour éteindre les jambes
puis en fait le haut du corps reprenait
feu donc ils s'en sortait pas en fait et
puis là un client qui était avec lui
rien un peu autour de lui pris un
extincteur puis là il m'a été avec
l'extincteur alors les ambulanciers sont
dépassés par les événements parce que
vos poumons sont brûlés votre peau est
carbonisée et votre peau en fait fait
une carapace autour de vous qui vous
empêche de respirer ouais ça devenait de
plus en plus compliqué à respirer entre
le temps où j'ai mon accident et
le moment où l'hélicoptère est arrivé
avec le médecin urgentiste il s'est
passé pas loin d'une heure ou je suis
resté conscient alors je me souviens pas
de tout c'était vraiment des comme ça
dernière chose que je me souvienne
réellement c'est le bruit de
l'hélicoptère qui atterrit et après non
mais par contre j'étais encore conscient
parce que le médecin urgentiste m'a dit
part après que c'est moi qui lui avait
répondu parce qu'il a demandé ce qui se
passait ce qui avait et puis c'est moi
qui lui ai répondu d'une voix très haut
qui m'a dit mazout alors voilà l'hôpital
en vous plonge dans un coma artificiel
92% de la surface de votre corps est
brûlé au troisième degré et là les
médecins se disent vu son état est-ce
qu'on devrait pas tout simplement le
débrancher ils en parlent à vos proches
faut-il envisager l'immense travail de
reconstruction qui va y avoir sur vous
c'était une question je pense que c'est
bien qu'il se la pose parce
qu'effectivement c'est pas parce que ils
m'ont sorti d'affaires qu'il faut
forcément on se dit ouais 92% peut
sauver on va le faire automatiquement
alors les médecins quelque part à partir
de 8% de votre peau qui sont restés
intactes le bassin les parties génitales
les pieds et une partie du crâne et là
il cultive des cellules de peau à partir
de votre peau et il recréer 1,3 m² de
peau et ensuite il vous greffe cette
peau voilà exacte alors après trois
semaines de coma artificiel quand vous
vous réveillez
Karine est à votre chevet et vous lui
dites je ne serai plus jamais celui que
tu as connu si tu veux me quitter Karine
je comprendrais
ouais je me devais de lui laisser le
choix quoi et puis alors j'espère
reconnaître la réponse parce qu'on était
assez fusionnel et tout mais je devais
lui laisser le choix de partir
évidemment elle vous répond je reste ce
qui s'est passé ce qui est
extraordinaire évidemment et donc 4 mois
après l'accident vous vous voyez donc
dans un miroir et vous vous dites ok je
suis comme ça c'est pas grave faut
avancer
c'était déjà accepté en fait j'ai eu
presque plus de peine à accepter mais ça
m'a fait plus drôle quand j'ai vu mes
mains et mes jambes en fait parce que
mes jambes à ce moment là j'avais plus
aucune musculature moi les premières
fois que je me suis qu'on m'a faisait et
que je me souviens mon poids de forme
c'est 70 kg là je faisais 47 kg puis les
mains je me suis tout de suite rendu
compte que ça allait rester handicap à
vie
alors votre reconstruction va prendre
deux ans une centaine d'anesthésie
générale ne serait-ce que pour enlever
les pansements voilà 27 opérations
et Karine aussi va être obligé de se
reconstruire parce que elle qui faisait
sa prière tous les soirs avant de se
coucher se demande pourquoi le ciel l'a
frappé alors ça je l'ai appris après
mais effectivement
elle faisait
c'était c'était ça devait pas nous
arriver quoi mais ça va arriver à
personne
le 17 février 2001 la neuf mois après
l'accident vous vous mariez
alors les pansements aux mains sont
énormes ils sont comme des gants de boxe
et il faut vous enlever les pansements
pour que vous puissiez enfiler votre
veste de mariage c'est les infirmières
qui m'ont passé mon costard le costard
que j'avais acheté avant l'accident
et quand vous signez le registre du
mariage évidemment vous pouvez pas
signer vous avez toujours ces gros
pansements sur les mains et votre
beau-père vous scotch un stylo sur le
pansement c'est beau ouais c'était un
mouvement
[Musique]
l'alliance bah vous l'apportez plus au
doigt évidemment vous la portez autour
du cou sur une chaîne et puis la vie
reprend la vie reprend tout doucement
très simplement vous faites deux filles
avec Karine vous reprenez le sport il
est assez extraordinaire et en 2010 vous
courrez le marathon de New York en 3h26
alors
votre problème
c'est que votre peau a brûlé à 92% donc
la peau qu'on vous a greffé finalement à
partir de la vôtre ne transpire pas ce
qui fait que dès que vous faites des
efforts vous avez de la fièvre votre
température monte à 40 degrés voilà
ouais c'est ce qui m'arrive et puis en
fait moi dans un peloton je pense je
suis au départ je suis le seul à espérer
qu'il pleut vous
alors votre prochaine objectif
maintenant Sébastien c'est de faire un
Iron Man alors un Iron Man c'est 3,8 km
à la nage
180 km en vélo et 42 km de course à pied
c'est à dire un marathon
vous dites quoi qu'il arrive la vie vaut
le coup d'être vécu ouais la vie est
super belle quoi vous avez une [__] de
patate
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu